[Music]
I'm really excited to be teaching a
two-day workshop at the 2019 our studio
conference on SHINee and production I'll
be joined by a powerhouse of our studio
engineers and engineers outside of our
studio all of whom have a great
background in building out awesome
shinee applications and scaling them in
the enterprise in production so I'm
really looking forward to teaching this
workshop showing you some of the tips
and tricks as well as the processes and
cultures that you can adopt not to be
successful
bringing SHINee into production and
while pretty much everyone these days is
learning how to write Chinese and
there's tons of excellent material out
there to teach you how to build
beautiful excellent China applications
that do meaningful things there's a lot
less information on how to deploy and
scale and combat your IT department when
they ask you who's going to ensure this
application works 2:00 a.m. in the
morning when a thousand people are
trying to visit it so that's what this
course is designed to address we've
spent almost a year building tools and
processes to help you bring SHINee into
production and to make sure that our in
SHINee are first-class citizens in the
enterprise architecture this course will
cover all of those tools as well as
those processes and cultures that'll
teach you the language that DevOps teams
expect you to be able to speak and it'll
show you by the end of the course how do
you approach the problem of bringing
your shiny application to hundreds or
thousands of users really excited to see
you all our studio conference I'm
looking forward to all the great talks
that we have lined up I know I'm going
to learn a lot but for my colleagues at
our studio and all of the great our
users coming to the conference I'm also
really looking forward to teaching this
class it's going to be an excellent
opportunity for all of us to come
together discuss and learn what SHINee
and production really means so I'm
looking forward to seeing you check out
our website to learn more about the
conference
and shiny and proportion
[Music]
you